hey everybody what's going on bleh here
we are just 24 hours away from the
premiere of Conan on TBS at 11 o'clock
10:00 central and we're all very excited
we've been working very hard to put
together the show that hopefully you all
will enjoy you know I know a couple of
you out there probably looking to plan a
party a little conan party a little
cocoa party having some people over
getting some drinks and snacks again
sitting down and preparing to laugh so
us here at team cocoa thought we would
give you guys some tips on how to throw
the awesomest conan party ever
first of all you're gonna be laughing a
lot trust me you're gonna be laughing a
lot your throats probably gonna get
pretty dry you're gonna want something
to drink what better to drink and some
delicious orange soda look at that look
at that coming where do soda go get it
really delicious
terrible for you by the way terrible for
you delicious
it's gonna help lubricate the throat so
you can laugh more which is what we all
want maybe you're hungry you show up
good party you know you want to eat
something right away you just want to
get something in yeah
everybody loves Cheetos and their orange
that's right this is how I enjoy Cheetos
I just like pour him into a bowl I don't
go for the hands I just stick my face
right in it that's better enjoy Cheetos
no main event
yeah I'm Sam it's hard to swallow these
Cheetos I'm sorry I'm outside with the
main event Conan is on you want to sit
down you want to watch you're hungry you
want to eat you know when can lap on an
empty stomach
we've got just the answer what better
than a cocoa corn dog that's right now I
know what you're saying hey bleh that
just looks like a normal corn dog you're
right here is how to cocoa by your corn
dog you ready you get a corn dog okay
it's all pretty good right I like to
hold up my teeth like this then I bust
open damn it
this cheese sauce mmm delicious that's
right then I like to dip my corn dog
right on the top there look at that
Hey look at that it's a little cone in
that well Conan here new right there yep
complete the illusion
pen should draw a little face right on
there yep little cone and face you got a
little nose a little smiley face they're
not going as well as I'd planned that's
okay
look at that would be so hard to write
on a corn talk all you do to enjoy your
little cocoa corn dog
mmm that is a really interesting taste
so that is how you throw a team cocoa
party to reiterate first of all serve
the word soda then move to the Cheetos
whoa whoa boom
cocoa corn dogs feel free to go back in
double dipping is allowed mmm so
interesting of a taste make sure to
watch Conan 11:00 p.m. 10:00 central TBS
and community team cocoa calm this will
be live blogging the whole thing it's
going to be awesome guys thanks so much
hope you enjoy the show I'm gonna go
throw up
[Music]